- Early on,
as the clinical trials
were still progressing
and then at the
very earliest time
when they started
deploying this,
it became clear that
one of the adverse,
there was two in particular
that were popping up,
that my buddies at the FDA,
who were outside of
the review branch
that I was having
weekly zooms with,
said were being flagged.
And I was hearing it popping
up from other physicians.
One was
myocarditis,
which the FDA and
the CDC denied,
and the Israelis denied.
That's a story.
And how that, how that
finally came, became public.
And the other one
was reactivation of
latent DNA viruses,
shingles being a
notable example.
And so there's a number of these
large herpes like DNA viruses
that exist in our
bodies for most of us.
Cytomegalovirus is another one.
Epstein-Barr virus
is a major one.
And generally your
T-cells keep these guys,
you can think of it as Pandora's
box, keeps the lid shut
by, you know,
T-cell suppression.
And if you,
if you pull that suppression
off, the top pops open
and all the nasties fly
out of Pandora's box,
I think is a good
way to think about
these latent DNA viruses.
And it was clear that that
was happening after the jab.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a global clinical
research scholar
at Harvard Medical
School, a scientist,
an author, a speaker,
a bioethicist,
and the inventor of
mRNA vaccine technology,
Dr. Robert Malone.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you so much.
It's lovely to see you here
today on this rather cold
Saturday here in Virginia.
But it's sunny and
it's, you know,
it's looking like it's gonna
be a good year, I think.
- And you mentioned
to me that you were
just out on the farm.
So you're dressed down a bit
for your average
podcast appearance.
- Yeah, I had, I'm sorry.
This didn't get on
the schedule somehow
and I've got a bunch of hay
and straw that I have to stack.
We have a young foal in the barn
that's a little sketchy and
it's gonna be a cold night,
so we wanna make sure
he's well bedded down.
- Nice, well, then
we'll use your time well
so that you can get
to that, you know.
So when I was doing some
research for this interview,
your bio is basically
pages and pages.
I mean, we just picked
some highlights there,
but I was trying to remember
some of the chronology
of these last couple years,
which have gotten very weird
in light of COVID.
- Yeah, to say the least.
- But I'm actually, I'm to say
the least, to say the least.
And I'm actually not sure-
- I would say surreal.
- Surreal, yeah, exactly.
We are, we are in
the matrix now,
but I'm actually not sure
if I had heard of you before
that famous or infamous
appearance on Joe Rogan.
So maybe before we
get to what's happened
for the last couple years,
do you wanna just give
us a little bit of recap
of your career before that
that led to this moment?
And then that's really
where I wanna spend
most of the interview.
- Well, I'm, I don't want
to belabor this too much.
I'm a physician and a scientist
trained at UC San Diego,
Salk Institute, UC Davis,
and Northwestern
University Medical School
and Harvard University
Medical School.
So that's the high level.
I been passionate about
molecular biology and virology
pretty much my whole career.
And also virology, with
the vaccine emphasis,
which is kind of what's
brought me into the current.
And my focus back when I
was a graduate student,
was trying to understand
some fundamentals
about RNA structure function,
and particularly how RNA gets
inserted into a retrovirus.
And in order to ask
fundamental questions,
I had to design ways to
make large quantities
of purified RNA and
put it into cells
and detect its presence
and blah, blah, blah.
And it just happened, I
was in a gene therapy lab
working on gene therapy projects
when I had this
series of discoveries
that made me aware that
there was a potential
to use RNA as a drug
and of the various
applications for a gene therapy
or gene delivery system
that doesn't actually
work very well.
That being with the
cationic lipids.
But the kind of entry-level
application was vaccines.
And so that was the
origin of the DNA
and the RNA vaccine idea.
Fast forward through, you know,
a decade and a half of academia
at UC Davis School of Pathology,
U Maryland School of Pathology,
both teaching medical schools-
Medical students,
I'm sorry, pathology,
and then Armed
Forces University,
the health sciences,
where I helped set up the
clinical breast care program
in a research institute
in Windber, Pennsylvania.
I then started a
company called a INOVIO,
that's still running,
that was largely based
on my own technology
and that of others in
the field at the time.
And then the planes
hit the towers,
the investors for
INOVIO pulled back.
My wife and I were left
high and dry in Rockville.
And I reached out to a buddy
at the Business and
Economic Development office
at Maryland State, and he said,
hey, there's this new company
up in Frederick, Maryland
that I could probably
make a phone call
and you could get a job at.
That was DynPort
Vaccine Company,
which had just received,
what the technical term is,
the prime systems contract
for all bio-defense products
for the US Department
of Defense.
And so I became their
associate clinical director
and basically was involved
in clinical research
on virtually all
drugs, vaccines,
and monoclonal antibody products
that the DOD was
developing for bio-defense.
And that was really the
pivot point in my career
where I shifted from being
a discovery research guy
and finally had the realization
that the world really
doesn't need more
academic thought leaders.
It has plenty of those.
But what it does need is
people who can bridge the gap.
It's actually called the
Valley of Death, technically.
A term Phil Russell employed
between the discovery part
in actually making a product.
And I decided that I
had spent enough time,
various euphemisms come
to mind, let's say,
chasing academia
and decided that I
wanted to actually
try to make things that
made people's lives better
and resulted in products.
So I shifted gears
and really focused on
learning the trade of
clinical development,
regulatory affairs,
project management,
proposal development,
that whole toolkit
that goes into
being able to assemble teams
to solve complicated problems
and get them funded
in the space of the government,
in particularly
Department of Defense.
And I've, I've been
study section chair
on many large contract
bid selection processes.
I've served the government
in writing solicitations.
And then eventually I set up
my own consulting practice,
kind of got tired of working
for corporate America.
I'd worked for a Bill and
Melinda Gates funded company
called ArisGlobal TV
Vaccine Foundation,
also Path in Seattle.
Worked for Salve on as
their clinical director
for influenza vaccines.
You know, many of these kind
of things I just got tired of,
of working for corporate
and having to toe the line
and do the eight to five.
So I set up a
consulting practice
and that's kind of what
I've done ever since.
But given my background, I'm
known as a specialist in,
like I said, assembling teams
to solve complicated problems
and being really adept at
working at the interface
between industry
and the government.
That's an area that's
really hard to navigate.
Not very many people
have that whole skillset.
Maybe very, very few that,
that understand regulatory
affairs and clinical development
and all the other stuff,
and can talk govy talk,
but also can talk to
the private sector
and work with them.
So that was kind of my thing.
And I've been involved
in many outbreaks,
was right at the
tip of the spear
in drug repurposing for Zika.
Was really asked by
Department of Defense
and Defense Threat
Reduction Agency
to step in and solve a hot mess.
That was a small
mid-western company
that owned the rights to a-
I'm sorry, a Ebola
vaccine candidate
that they'd bought from
Canada for about $150,000.
And I carried that forward.
That was a, you
know, amazing time.
People were scared
outta their brains.
Ebola's a scary business.
Way more scary than
than the Corona.
And it drives people
crazy and, you know,
they'll shoot each other
and ebola's a scary disease.
And so I got Merck
involved in that project
and got them to buy the product
from the small
midwestern company,
and that's now the
Merck Ebola vaccine.
So I've been doing
this a long time.
And then, then, and when
you're in this space,
you touch on the intelligence
community all the time.
They are all thick
throughout bio-defense.
And so I've had many
contacts that have been CIA.
I'm not CIA.
I'm not trained CIA.
I have been security cleared
by the Department of Defense.
I'm sorry, Stu Peters,
you're wrong on that.
And George Webb,
but there it is.
- Yeah.
- You know, and so if you're
in this business area,
you touch on CIA
folk all the time.
And I've actually co-published
with one that is now a
retired CIA officer who
arguably is our top expert
in gain of function research.
A former project
manager at DARPA
named Dr. Michael Callahan,
who has an appointment
at Harvard.
And he called me up on January
2nd, 2020 or January 4th,
right around there and said,
Hey Robert, we got a problem.
This novel Coronavirus that's
circulating here in Wuhan,
looks like it's
gonna be a problem.
And that's what got me going.
And that's kind of where the,
the journey of the last
three years begins.
And I did a threat
assessment, as I always do.
He asked me to get my,
the group that I work
with kind of wound up
and ready to respond to this.
And I,
I did the usual threat
assessment and my sense was
that we could not build a
safe and effective vaccine
in time to really make an impact
as this would move as a
wave across the globe.
And that what we needed to
focus on was a repurpose drug.
So that's pretty much what I did
for the first third
of the last two years,
largely with DOD funding,
which I'm kind of
adroit at getting.
I captured, I don't know,
300 million for various projects
relating to drug repurposing.
And then actually the,
there was a series of
kind of red pill moments
and you mentioned Joe Rogan.
Before Joe Rogan,
there was the moment where
I got called by Steve Kirsch
to go on a podcast with this
guy I'd never heard of before.
I had hardly even
heard of podcasting.
And, and this guy, he,
the name of his podcast
was kind of scary.
I thought it referred
to the Dark Web,
it was the Dark Horse podcast,
and his name was
Brett Weinstein.
- Brett, Brett is a
good friend of mine.
And and I,
I was the first one that
ever publicly interviewed him
after he left Evergreen State,
or when he was in
the midst of that
now over there.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so we all kind of sat
around that little table,
three old men and,
and talked for a couple hours
and the world went crazy.
- Right. So, okay.
Now, now having
reminded me of that,
of course I knew of you
before the Rogan thing.
It's hard these last couple
years have been real fast, but,
alright, so let's pause
there for a second
'cause that'll kind of set us up
for, for the last, you know,
two and a half years or so.
And, and thank you for
doing some of the bio stuff.
So I didn't have to
read all of that.
But what I wanted to illustrate
there was that you've got
sort of the private sector,
you've got the government
sector, something related,
at least closely enough
To the intelligence sector.
- Nongovernmental organization
- Yeah.
- You know, I've,
I kind of been around the
block three or four times.
Academia.
- So.
So with all of that in mind,
let's just do some like basic
1 0 1 stuff for a moment
before we get to
your red pill moment.
When people are talking
about vaccines and,
and the difference between
these mRNA vaccines
and how we've always
done vaccines previously,
can you give us just like a,
like a high level
version of that and,
and sort of when did you
become concerned that there was
a difference in what
was going on here?
- So I think what
you're talking about
is not what is the
nature of a vaccine
in terms of the technology,
but rather what
is the process to-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Bring a vaccine to market
and that's typically
about a 10 year timeline.
To illustrate the point,
the Department of Defense,
if everything goes
well, and it never does,
is on track to have
vaccines licensed
for all infectious
disease agents
that were deployed
in bio warfare
up until the end
of World War II.
And if everything goes right,
they'll have all those
vaccines by 2050,
A full century after
the end of World War II.
- [Dave] Right.
Right.
- Okay, so we gotta,
we gotta basically a 10,
10 year timeline to
really do it right.
And that involves significant
non-clinical research,
toxicology, pharmaco
distribution, genotoxicity,
a whole bunch of things
that just got blown off
to make sure that,
that it's safe enough to go
into humans in the first place.
And then once it's
in humans, it go,
typically a vaccine goes
through a very staged process
of phase one trials,
typically a couple of
different phase one trials,
phase two expanded trials.
Phase one is typically just
kind of preliminary estimates
of safety with low numbers.
You know, here's an
important thing to know.
In vaccinology we use
the rule of three.
And the way this works
is if you wanna detect
an adverse event that occurs
in one in a thousand people,
generally you have
to test 3000 people.
If you wanna detect something
that happens one in 30, okay.
Or one in 10, I was
gonna say one in 10,
then you'd have to
test 30 people, okay.
So that's kind of
phase one trial.
- [Dave] Right.
Level one in, you know,
one in 10 is stuff
that happens a lot,
pretty much to everybody, right?
One of the thousand is,
is something that matters
a lot if you're gonna be
administering it to
large populations.
Which generally is the
case with vaccines,
unless you're talking
about special forces
or something for some
obscure pathogen.
And then when you
really get to, you know,
global deployment or
national deployment,
you want to have sample sizes
in the kind of 300,000 range.
You know, the,
this is what the FDA has
typically required in the past
for new adjuvants, for
example, for a vaccine.
But in this case,
kind of all the rules went
out the door in the rush,
in all the fear that
was actively promoted.
So when you, when you do
it that step-wise fashion,
and then typically
what happens is you,
you first kind of
move it forward in
healthy normal adults.
Because they have lowest
risks, they can handle insults,
biologic insults best.
And then,
then you move to elderly
people and special populations
like immunosuppressed and
those kinds of things.
And you do a step down into
the little babies, okay?
So first you do adolescents
and then you do,
at first you do young adults,
then you do adolescents,
then you do children, then
you do, you know, young,
very young, and
then you can go down
to neonates if you have to.
So that's the general process.
And to do all that takes
enormous amount of time.
And the cost per subject for
a well-run trial is something,
it starts at about
10,000 per person.
Generally if you, if you
really mind your nickels,
you can get it down to about
five or 8,000 per person,
and it goes up to about
30 or 40,000 per person.
So you can do the math and
you quickly come up to some
serious, serious cash.
So it, it takes, you know,
billions of dollars, years
and years to do this safely.
And as you've seen,
the decision was to
rush the whole thing,
bypass almost everything
and start administering it into
a very broad population,
a global population.
And do so.
Also bypassing this
key thing that was,
we all agreed on in the
western world, at least.
After World War II called
the Nuremberg Accords
and the Helsinki Accords.
And then in, in
moving to the present,
we call this the common rule.
In which people have to be
granted informed consent.
And you absolutely cannot
coerce, compel, or entice
people to take an
unlicensed medical product.
That has just historically
been off limits.
We all agreed, nope,
Germans did that.
You know, everybody
thinks about what happened
in Nazi Germany.
The story of what happened
in Japan is even uglier.
The Japanese bio warfare
program was, you know,
truly atrocious in
terms of the bioethics.
And as I guess Bobby is gonna
point out in his next book.
- Bobby Kennedy.
- Just like we imported a lot
of the rocket scientists to
launch NASA, so to speak,
we imported both German,
but particularly the
Japanese bio warfare experts
and the records associated
with that up to Fort Dietrich
in Frederick, Maryland to
launch our bio warfare program.
which after Nixon
made the determination
that we were gonna put in place,
the bio warfare
treaty got transformed
into a bio-defense program.
The same people doing the
same stuff pretty much.
And that's, that's kind
of where that's all gone.
It's, it's not a pretty picture.
And, and the deeper
you look into it,
and the bio labs that
we set up in Georgia,
the former Soviet state,
and then presumably the bio
labs that we set up in Ukraine,
those, those offshore bio labs
have a long, rich history
of ethical abuses,
let's say gently.
So it's a mixed bag here.
There's a lot of,
there's, there's.
I do believe that
there is an unmet need
and that was the logic
for advancing the RNA tech
in theory was there
absolutely is an unmet need
for ability to respond rapidly
to engineered pathogens and
emerging infectious disease.
But I think personally
that what's been done
will basically destroy global
public confidence in any of
this kind of activity for
the foreseeable future.
- Yeah, I think,
I think we've done that already
and God only knows where
that leads us when, when
something really big hits.
But I, so I wanna
back up for a second.
So when you got that call
around the second or fourth of,
of January,
back in 2020
Now warp speed was basically
a couple months later.
- Yeah.
- What were you warn,
what were you warning
about at that point?
I mean, were you basically
trying to get information
to the administration to say,
don't rush this thing
because God only knows
what's gonna happen
or what the vaccine injuries
are gonna be, et cetera,
et cetera, putting aside
the coercion and everything.
- Yeah, so actually
Callahan, I sent.
We launched a drug
discovery program
involving repurposed drugs
that was absolutely cutting
edge computational modeling.
We screened the entire library
of all known licensed drugs
as well as nutraceuticals.
And we came up with a
ranked list of agents.
And then I was at a drug
discovery conference involving
artificial intelligence
and machine learning at MIT
in the end of February, 2020.
And I got infected with
the original Wuhan strain
in that first wave that
moved through Boston.
And came home, wasn't even aware
that the virus had hit
Boston at that point.
We all thought it was in
Seattle and, you know,
starting to trickle
into New York.
And my wife came in
and as I'm laying sick
as a dog in the bed
and said, hey Robert,
you know what?
You probably got this one.
And at that point,
as somebody with the
background in pathology
and working with a
very strong team,
including other pathologists,
I was of the belief
that this was,
this was likely to be lethal.
Or at a minimum to cause
a progressive interstitial
pulmonary fibrosis,
which is basically to say
lingering death from
loss of lung function.
And so that was kind of grim.
And, and I started.
- That's what, that's just
what you were feeling,
just based on how you
felt at the time that?
- Yeah, and, and I, I was sick,
I was really sick.
And burning lungs.
You know, lots, lots
of symptoms and.
So, I was embarrassed to do
it, but outta desperation,
I started taking the drugs
that we'd identified.
It's generally not kosher
to experiment on yourself
in terms of medical ethics.
But you know, you're lying here.
There's no drugs, there's no
docs that know how to treat it.
Here in Virginia, they, they
didn't even have any testing.
You know, I called up the
public health service and said,
hey, I need to get the
definitive diagnosis.
And they said, well, if
you think you have it,
you probably do.
And, you know, that was
about it in February.
- So then you test on yourself
like every bad guy in a
Marvel movie, basically.
- Yeah, I started trying
the drugs and I tried.
Everybody's really
hot on quercetin,
it's in many of the protocols.
For me, quercetin
and isoquercetin was
just a bust, nothing.
But I took famotidine,
this Pepcid drug,
and suddenly, you
know, within an hour,
I had a clinical response.
My lungs stopped burning,
I could breathe better.
And I was like, okay,
this is kind of important.
So we really chased the
treck tail on that one
and eventually got it
into clinical trials
and got papers published
and some couldn't get
published once they started
blocking all publication
of repurposed drugs.
And we continued on and,
and in a contract with MIT,
Lincoln Labs really
identified, racked and stacked
a whole bunch of agents that
we're all familiar with now,
for, you know, the DOD,
potentially for the war fighter.
And then, and then this
buzz started with the,
with the jabs and what
had been done with OWS
and people started
contacting me for information
because everybody was
confused and intimidated
by this acronym, RNA.
What does this all mean?
You know, you know,
no one would talk.
And so it was ring
up Robert Malone
and hope he could
shed some light.
And that's what kind of
set that ball rolling.
So that, that,
I hope that fills in
some of the gaps for you.
- Yeah. So,
so as now they're rolling out
warp speed and you realize
that this technology that you
were one of the experts on
and had the patents on all
this stuff and everything else,
as you realize that this is
going to be now pushed really
on everyone in America
with all this, you know,
the companies were
gonna have no liability
and all of this crazy stuff.
What was your first red
pill moment related to that?
When did you realize that
something was wrong here?
- Well, I realized
something was wrong
when the book that my
wife is the primary author
and me as the author,
put together in February,
really in January and published
in the beginning of February,
called How to Prepare
and Protect Yourself
From the Novel Coronavirus
got censored in March
and taken to Amazon.
So that, that, and,
and the justification,
it took us forever to finally
get them to fess up as to why
'cause their usual
policies, they'll tell you.
You know, oh,
there's porn on page 52 or
whatever the thing is, right?
You fat shame somebody.
- [Dave] Right.
- Whatever your sin is,
they'll usually tell you.
- Yeah.
- Um,
they wouldn't tell us.
- Although,
in the case of COVID,
a little fat shaming probably
would help, but okay.
- Yeah, but that's not
allowed these days.
So.
- Yeah.
- Any case, finally,
the other shoe drops,
we have violated
community standards.
What are those
community standards?
Undefined, but we,
we violated them.
Okay, so that's the first
time I ever heard that phrase.
And so it went.
There was a series of things,
but in terms of the jab,
a couple of key things.
Both of which involved Canadians
really crystallized
things for me.
I got a, a call about
from really outta desperation
from a Canadian physician
practicing in Toronto who
wants to be not named.
His office has been broken in,
his computer has been
trashed by the government.
I mean, he's totally been
targeted for the sin of
prescribing ivermectin
and hydroxychloroquine
and saving people's lives.
But he called me in with,
brokered by Steve Kirsch
and on a Saturday evening,
seems forever go,
and was just appealing to me,
hoping that I could get through
to the Canadian
regulatory authorities.
And help them understand
what was really going on.
He, you know, kind of naively.
And I had already managed,
I had already called in and
had conversations and was,
had ongoing conversations
with senior people at the FDA,
but I don't know anybody in
the Canadian
regulatory authority
and I don't even know the
Canadian regs that well.
And so I had to say
to him, you know,
we had this long conversation
where he was telling me about
how they were deleting any
records that he would enter
having to do with adverse
events of his patients
after they took the jab
and just totally disregarding
what he was
observing clinically.
And furthermore, they were,
the government was
enticing children
to take the jab with ice creams.
And, and for me, this
was an ethical horror.
I'd never heard of
anything like this.
You know, this is what I've
been trained to never do.
You know, on pain of,
of losing my ability
to ever practice
clinical research again.
And so I had to tell him,
we talked until
midnight and I said,
there's nothing
I can do for you.
I just don't know.
I don't know who to call.
I don't know what to say.
And I woke up in the morning
and my wife and I are both
well trained in bioethics.
My mentor in bioethics
was her PhD mentor,
a guy named Itel Shamu.
And, and I woke up and I said,
Jill, I know what we can
do for this poor guy.
We can publish an article on
the bioethics of what's
going on with these vaccines
and the failure to
enable informed consent
and the enticement and coercion
and what is the history of the
bioethics rules that apply,
et cetera.
And so that was, that
was the first big one.
And I think that was
the first article out
that really drilled
into what was going on
wrong with the bioethics.
- So, so basically,
so basically you
first were concerned
just about informed consent.
This is before you
had any sense of
what the vaccine
injuries might be, right?
So this is just about-
- Well, I had, so.
So at that point, I'm
skating on thin ice.
I'm hearing these injuries.
And I know,
I'm seeing the amazing
that's going on
and gas lighting and, you know,
information control
and everything,
blacklisting that's going on.
And so I'm trying
to figure out, okay,
how can I navigate this,
this minefield?
And say something that
will move the ball forward
and get everybody
to see that this is,
this isn't right,
what's going on,
without just getting,
you know, my head cut off
and labeled as an
anti-vaxxer nutcase.
You know, obviously I didn't
succeed very well in that,
but that was, that
was the attempt was
to thread the needle.
- Yeah.
- And I thought that
bioethics was something
where I clearly had the core
expertise and competence.
I was absolutely on the right.
I mean, there's no ifs, ands,
or buts about this topic
in terms of what is
right and proper.
And so I thought,
well, this is one thing I can
do here that should be able to
penetrate through the mainstream
media and get people to.
That's what I focused on
and that's focused on
for quite a few months,
was just trying to be the
voice of responsible bioethics
and drive that home.
- And was any of that breaking
through to mainstream media?
- Of course not.
- I actually don't recall
seeing you.
Yeah, I was gonna say,
I don't recall seeing you
on CNN or on Meet the Press
or anything.
- No, well, of course not.
- So basically you try.
- Yeah. So so.
- You try that for a while
and then
- In parallel.
- Yeah.
- U Pen and BioNTech
were aggressively
marketing two characters
for the Nobel Prize.
Katie Kariko and Drew Weissman.
And Katie is a
former Hungarian spy
and Drew is a former
Tony Fauci post-doc,
both of whom ended
up working at U Penn.
And their,
this is about a decade later
from after what I did my work.
And they had this
discovery that they could
use pseudouridine in the RNA
and get more immune response.
And they were being
marketed aggressively
'cause this is what, you know,
this is one way to play the game
if you want to get a Nobel
Prize for your institution
as the inventors of this
whole technology and concept.
And I was just kind of pissed
about being written
outta history.
And so I objected to that.
Then this huge marketing
campaign came at
me about, oh, you,
you're absolutely
not the inventor.
You're lying, you're
misrepresenting, you know,
you're misrepresenting your cv.
And it's all about Katie
and Drew and, you know,
New York Times and
CNN interviews for
them and everything.
And so I, I just became
a very inconvenient
squeaky wheel in that
whole environment.
And then when I'm
coming out with this
messaging about bioethics,
I was already kind
of got the black spot
despite having worked with
media for almost two decades,
usually on background.
The reason why you never
heard of me before is there,
I I have had multiple
hard lessons in the,
the wisdom of the
common DC saying,
if they can't see you,
they can't shoot you.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And, and I, I've, you
know, as a consultant,
I've been able to do what I did
by staying behind the scenes,
letting my clients
take the credit
and just kind of laying low
and getting my business
done and collecting my fee.
So that was a longstanding
intentional strategy.
Department of Defense
in particular,
but most clients really
don't like to have
the consultant be out front.
- Right, so you have the
initial issue is the coercion,
then the vaccines are out.
You already had heard
of some vaccine injuries
and things of that nature.
But when did it shift, yeah?
- And then this other Canadian
comes in, Byron Brighton.
- Yeah.
- So Byron, who I'd
never heard of before,
but he's an absolutely well
qualified vaccinologist
immunologist academic.
University of Gelf.
Is that right?
I think.
I may be confusing him
with Mattias Desmet.
So forgive me if I did.
So Byron apparently
manages to grab
the common technical
document for the Pfizer
submission for allowance
to proceed in humans.
So common technical document,
we used to call those INDs.
It's the dossier of everything
they know about the product
and that they used to justify
initiating clinical trials.
And, and usually those are
considered confidential.
So the likes of you
and I can't get at them
because otherwise we
would be able to go
and try to reverse engineer
whatever the new product is.
And so for whatever reason,
the Japanese apparently
put this, you know.
Common technical document is
basically universal document
that gets submitted to
all regulatory agencies
all over the world.
And they'd put it on a server
and Byron had
somehow grabbed it,
or one of his buddies
had and sent it to him
and he'd done an analysis of it.
Most of it's in Japanese,
but the figures and
legends are in English.
And so he went through that
and he was pretty
shocked by what he found,
but he's not a
regulatory affairs expert
and he doesn't have
the kind of, you know,
hybrid experience I have.
So he asked a buddy of mine
that runs the company called
Trial Site News
to see whether or not I
would take a look at it.
So it comes to me right
after it goes to Byron
and I'm asked to do an
independent assessment
and I read through the thing
and I'm pretty shocked and,
at how shoddy it is.
It's just, it's atrocious
and shocking to me
that this would be
submitted for anything.
I mean, if I submitted that,
I would expect to
get reprimanded,
if not basically tarred
and feathered by the FDA.
- Was that basic,
was that because of the efficacy
of what you were seeing?
What, what was the most shocking
part of it?
- No, it was just,
there was no real efficacy data.
They weren't even testing
the real drug product.
They were substituting
an mRNA coating
for a firefly
protein luciferase.
- So it was the methodology
of the whole thing, basically?
- It was completely
inadequate by any standards
that I had been trained on.
Completely inadequate
as a package.
And so I wrote up my assessment
and I was so concerned by what
I thought I saw, you know.
This can't possibly
be coming from Pfizer,
this can't possibly
be, you know,
I must be missing something.
So I sent it to a more
senior regulatory affairs guy
that I know that I
used to work with
at another contract
research organization.
And he looked it
over and he said,
oh yeah, Robert, everything
you said here is true,
but you missed a
couple of other.
And so I said, well,
okay, that's great.
I need to write this up now as
an essay for Trial Site News.
Do you want your name on it?
He's like, no, no, no, no, no!
Don't put my name anywhere,
anywhere near this thing!
So I boldly went where
angels fear to tread
and put that thing out.
And Byron in
parallel, put his out.
And I've, I've since met and,
and spent time with Byron,
he tells a story up in Canada
that he was scared silly
of what I was gonna say.
He thought I was this big,
intimidating, nasty guy
and I was gonna
tear him to shreds.
And when I basically
piped up on the,
on the zoom call that we
had over this and said,
Byron, I agree with
everything you've said,
plus there's these other things.
He was completely relieved.
But that's, that's how
that came to be is,
is that's how I ended up
being one of the first,
if not the first, to
me and Byron at least,
to really break the story
that the regulatory package
that Pfizer had submitted
was grossly inadequate.
That set off a cascade of
me talking to Peter Marks.
And you know, I, at that point,
I was still assuming that the
FDA was acting in good faith.
And my core assumption was that
Pfizer had pulled a
fast one on the FDA.
That the FDA didn't have
sufficient scientific expertise
to understand what
they were looking at.
They couldn't possibly!
There's no way this could
get through the FDA.
The only way I could
imagine would be if they,
if the people that were
doing the reviewing
just didn't understand
what they were looking at.
And so I offered my help
to Peter Marks and said,
you know, I understand
all this tech.
And he basically told
me to go pound sand and,
and that another body of data
had been submitted by Pfizer.
And he'd reviewed that
and he actually asked me to
be quiet about my concerns,
to give him time to disclose
what was in this
new Pfizer dossier.
Which we now know
the FDA and Pfizer
tried to withhold from
the public for 75 years,
until the courts forced them to.
And so basically I got
lied to by Peter Marks,
but that now in retrospect
shouldn't surprise me.
- What's so
fascinating about this,
beyond the science that's
obviously fascinating,
is that you're sort of
laying out the story
of your red pilling in essence
because every step
of the way here,
there's some
regulatory commission
or some sort of
censorious outlet that's,
that's kind of stopping you
or that even there
you still are saying
you had this belief that
the FDA would stop it.
So when did,
when did you realize that
it sort of seemed like
the entire machinery
was either broken
or my words just
outright negligent?
- That's a, that's
a good question.
As the adverse events piled up,
and, and I,
I'm vaccine injured.
I took the jab,
I took Moderna when
the National Guard
was deploying it here
in Central Virginia.
I was scheduled for
a talk in France
and I knew I couldn't go
if I didn't take the jab.
And I had long COVID and
there was a whole lot of press
that long COVID could be, could
benefit from taking the jab.
We now know that's a lie, but,
you know, more propaganda.
- How skeptical were you?
I mean, knowing that
you had had COVID.
Okay, you had long COVID,
but you had done research.
I mean, how skeptical were you?
I get you wanna
go to France, but
- About the jab, so.
So I, I had, number one,
in good faith,
I'd assumed that my colleagues
that I had known for decades
must have had a.
Another part of the story
that we didn't cover
is that Jill and I
worked on this tech
for over a decade in academia.
At California Regional
Private Research Center
at Bounces Labs, at U Maryland.
And we abandoned it
because we could never
overcome the toxicity.
And we have multiple
other patents.
I mean, this wall behind
me is all patents,
multiple other patents for
different cationic lipids,
different formulations.
We published the first
stuff on use of cholesterol,
which is in these formulations.
And early on I called up
a guy at University of British
Columbia, Peter Culles,
who I'd known for quite a while,
who was the one
that had really made
the breakthroughs
to enable this,
this version that
was being deployed.
And I had faith that they
had solved those problems
that we had not
been able to solve.
- [Dave] Hmm.
- So I was still
operating assuming that
they had overcome
the things that had
bedeviled us for a decade.
- That's a heck of a
leap of faith, huh?
- Well, I think it's reasonable.
I mean, you,
you can assume that
people are are nefarious
or you can assume that
people are generally good.
And I prefer to assume that
Although I gotta say,
the last three years
that's taken a pretty hard hit.
- Yeah.
- But I still,
I still approach the
world with an open heart.
I try hard to.
- Yeah.
- And I try hard to have
faith in my fellow man
and I employ the three strikes
rule, generally speaking.
You know, takes three
strikes for me to say,
I just don't wanna deal
with that person again.
I extended trust to
my former colleagues
believing that
they must have had
the breakthrough that they
asserted that they had had.
And obviously in retrospect,
they had convinced
themselves as a,
as a community of
a number of things,
such as minor modifications
in the structure
of the positively charged fat
would lead to formulations,
which would target specific
organ systems or tissues.
And so they, they
had published and,
and it was believed
in the field that
these modified versions.
In my lab, we'd built
hundreds of different
cationic lipid compounds
and tested them at Genzyme.
They tested thousands
or tens of thousands
when they were
trying to get agents
to treat cystic fibrosis.
So I knew how the
game was played and
the literature suggested that
there'd been some kind of
serendipitous magic findings
that if you use this
structure and you injected it,
it would only go to the lymph
nodes and it would stay there.
And you'll recall, that's
what we were all told.
And yet,
that wasn't true.
It was clearly not true based
on the Pfizer data package
that Byron Bridal had obtained.
So, you know, when you're,
when you're in, you know,
you spent your whole
career working in an area,
you have all these
relationships with people,
professional relationships.
To break out of that and,
and say, oh, you know,
all these things I thought
were this way, were wrong.
And for me,
so I not only had that on
kind of a micro level in this
little bubble of
this technology,
but I think we've all had that,
those of us that are awake
have had that same experience
about our government, media,
military, all, you know,
globalism, you know.
I knew the World
Health Organization
was corrupt as the day is long
because I'd been there
a number of times
and spoken and dealt with them.
But the scope of what
we'd been dealing with,
I think for all of
us, pretty much,
at least I, had assumed that
the world was a
very different place
and that people acted with
integrity, Generally speaking.
I wrote a essay about
this on Substack
where I talked about
peeling off layers of naivete
and I'm still not sure I've
peeled off all the layers
of my naivete.
I'm sure there's,
there's more to go, but.
- There's, there's
always another layer.
There's always another layer.
So all of this is
happening and now you're,
you're being red pilled because
you're seeing it through
not only colleagues,
but you're seeing it through
the regulatory commission.
You seeing it through
the media.
- And I've experience it
myself, okay.
On jab two,
I developed hypertension
to 230 systolic
and pod narcolepsy
and restless leg.
And, you know,
all those at the time
were not cataloged
as adverse events, but we
now know that they are.
- So, so I saw you,
I saw a clip of you on
Twitter a few weeks ago
that no longer exists, but
I saw it with my own eyes.
So unless it was a
deep fake, I saw it,
it was not from your account,
it was from someone
else's account.
Where in essence, what
you were saying was,
and clean this up
for me, if I'm,
if I'm getting it
slightly wrong,
that basically some
level of the mRNA vaccine
is sort of like a low grade HIV.
In that it is degrading
people's immune systems.
It's hitting the t-cells
so now other dormant
viruses are now popping up.
Things like shingles.
- So that was not
that's not a deep fake.
I don't know that I used
the reference to aids only.
If I did, it would be a
reference to an autoimmune.
Or I'm sorry,
an immunodeficiency syndrome.
- Yeah, you did.
Yes, you made a point of
differentiating between
HIV and AIDS in the clip, yeah.
- Yeah, so acquired
immunodeficiency
syndrome is the,
is what the.
And so if you do
something, you know,
you're in, in a
state and then you,
then something happens and you
become more immunodeficient,
you've acquired an
immunodeficiency
syndrome, right?
So that's, that's the tie in.
AIDS is actually a big basket
into which you can throw
all kinds of things.
So early on,
it just as the clinical
trials were still progressing,
and then at the very earliest
time when they started
deploying this, it became
clear that one of the adverse.
There was two in particular
that were popping up,
that my buddies at the FDA
who were outside of
the review branch
that I was having
weekly zooms with,
said were being flagged.
And I was hearing it popping
up from other physicians.
One was myocarditis,
which the FDA and the CDC denied
and the Israelis
denied, that's a story.
And how that, how that
finally came became public.
And the other one
was reactivation of
latent DNA viruses,
shingles being a
notable example.
And so there's a number
of these large herpes-like
DNA viruses that exist in
our bodies for most of us.
Cytomegalovirus is another one.
Epstein-Barr virus
is a major one.
And generally your
T-cells keep these guys,
you can think of it
as Pandora's box,
keeps the lid shut by, you
know, T-cell suppression.
And if you,
if you pull that suppression
off, the top pops open
and all the nasties fly
outta Pandora's box,
I think is a good
way to think about
these latent DNA viruses.
And it was clear that that
was happening after the jab.
It's, it's one of the major,
it appears now to be
one of the major causes
of the kind of shorter term,
short to intermediate
term long COVID symptoms,
particularly Epstein-Barr virus.
So that's what I
was referring to.
Now, fast forward to
yesterday or the day before
when Veritus dropped this
third video from Dr. Walker,
I assume now formerly Pfizer
worldwide director of mRNA
vaccine or mRNA strategies
in which he talks about
the
hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal
axis.
That, what he's
basically saying there,
is that Pfizer believes that
the menstrual irregularities
are really kind of the
tip of the iceberg.
And that this thing is
damaging a fundamental aspect
of your endocrine system.
Your endocrine system
controls your energy,
it controls your sex drive,
it controls all
kinds of development.
It controls your mental state,
whether you're depressed
or excited or whatever.
It controls your digestion.
I mean, it's, your endocrine
system is hugely important.
Endocrine abnormalities
can be associated
with cardiac problems.
And they can absolutely,
they are absolutely
endocrine fluctuations
impact on your immune function.
So now, now we have,
in addition to the
huge laundry list
that we already had of
potential causes, you know,
in terms of the pathophysiology
for why we're seeing these
immunologic
suppression phenotypes,
particularly the more
people get jabbed.
But now we have another one,
which is the damage to the
hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal
axis.
- So, so where, where
are we at right now?
I mean, everything
you're saying.
- We're deep in a hole
and continuing to dig.
- I mean, I mean, how concerned-
So I'm not vaxxed.
The two guys that are in
this room that work for me,
are not vaxxed.
One of the reasons I did
not get Vaxxed was because,
oh, first off, I'm
relatively young and healthy
and take good care of myself,
but the more that they pushed,
for some reason that was
igniting something in me
and I just could
not give into that.
- Good for you.
- And you know, the
other part, Dr. Malone,
was that when they really
were pushing this idea
of the employer mandates,
I kept thinking,
well, I don't have a,
I don't have a
thousand employees,
but even if I did,
what right would I have
to say to somebody,
you have to inject yourself
with something to work for me?
- Yeah, so,
so clearly you were never
going to be a major CEO
of a large American corporation
because you have a conscience.
- I suppose that
ship has sailed.
I got a couple small businesses.
I'm doing okay.
But having heard everything
you've said here,
especially these
last few minutes,
I mean people have now,
some people have gotten
five or six jabs.
- Yeah.
- We know that people are
getting shingles and myocarditis
and I have a young friend
with heart problems now.
- Remember when I was on Rogan,
I said those three little words
that caused Google and
all of Silicon Valley,
I like to say-
- I know, I can do it.
- Mass formation.
- Mass formation psychosis.
- Yeah. So a good fraction
of the world is hypnotized.
They, they have succumb.
So here's how I
like to frame this
'cause I'm really trying
to focus on healing.
I'm a physician.
I mean, I could have gone into
developing nuclear
warheads like my dad did,
or spy equipment like
my father-in-law did.
No, I wanted to go
into medicine, I
wanted to heal people.
The whole world has been
subjected to three years of
military-grade
psychological operations
that it basically
is fifth generation
warfare battlefield tactics
that have been deployed,
designed for fighting Al-Qaeda,
deployed against
our own citizens.
Okay?
So, military grade PSYOPs
deployed particularly in
the five eyes countries,
Great Britain, United
States, Canada,
New Zealand, and Australia.
This spy alliance that is
one of the most powerful
organizations in the world.
And for some reason,
those are the countries
that seem to have had
the most egregious authoritarian
responses and censorship,
et cetera.
So, so everybody has been
subjected to military-grade
information warfare technology.
And some of us, like yourself,
reacted to it and said,
oh no, if they're pushing
this hard, this can't be good.
I, I'm I'm out.
Or whatever the reason was
that caused people to wake up.
Mattias tells the story
that for him it was gradual.
Mattias Desmet,
he's been teaching mass
formation in the work of
Hannah Arendt and
Gustave Le Bon.
He's a professor, this
is what he teaches.
And and he didn't
realize it first.
It kind of gradually
dawned on him
as things were going along.
You know, he said, holy moly!
Well, that's not what he said,
but you get the picture.
What's happening is exactly
what I've been teaching
underneath my nose and I
didn't even realize it.
So my point is, everybody
has been subjected to this,
something like 15 to 25% of
people were resistant to it
or woke up.
And the rest, for
whatever reason,
were not able to fight off
the psychological warfare
that was deployed against them.
Should we hate them?
Or should we say, you know,
first off we can
kind of pat ourselves
on the back a little bit.
Good boy.
- Yeah.
- We resisted the PSYOPs.
- That's nice for a day or two
- Gold star.
- Yeah.
- Right?
But I argue, you know,
and this does not apply,
let's say gently
to Tony Fauci and-
- Sure.
- Jacinda Ardern and Justin
Trudeau and Rochelle Walensky
and you know, we can go on
and on with the names, Tedros.
I'm not saying those folks,
but for the folks that you
meet in the grocery store
that are still
wearing face nozzles.
- The people who got duped.
- And who are putting face
nozzles on their little kids
and everything,
and even the ones that
said just ugly, ugly stuff,
you know,
they were so wrapped up in
the tribalism that they,
they said some,
there's some pretty nasty things
and some pretty nasty policies.
Oh, you can't have
a heart transplant
if you don't take the jab.
Or we're, you know, we,
people that haven't taken the
jab should be allowed to die
or they should be put
into camps or, you know,
we can go on and on with the
ugly, ugly stuff that was said.
I argue that for the most
part, those poor souls
were victims of a
psychological warfare campaign
that was deployed on them.
And if we think of it that way,
we might be able to
open our hearts to them.
And if we don't open our hearts,
we can't bring them
over to our side.
We can never convince
them by hating them.
And we need them.
We need the persuadable
middle if we're gonna win this
and we're gonna, you know,
not have to live under
the thumb of Klaus Schwab
and all of his minions.
We need each other.
We don't need to be split apart.
So that's, that's my
preaching on the propaganda
and fifth generation
warfare story
that has, you know, all of
us have been subjected to.
- It's kind of nice, I mean,
you spent your life trying
to heal through science
and now you're trying
to heal, heal through,
I suppose something that's a
little more spiritual perhaps.
I should probably
end it there, but,
but I do want to ask
you one, one more thing,
because that does feel like
the sort of positive ending.
But, but now having
all of this said,
how worried are
you that millions,
I don't know how many
hundreds of millions of people
throughout the world
have taken this vaccine.
We're seeing the
vaccine injuries.
Many people have taken,
you know, the fifth booster
or whatever it might be,
and that the litany of health
problems that we're gonna see
and then what would could
be emotional problems
and all of the other stuff that,
that we're just at the
beginning basically of,
of the damage of this stuff
that almost has nothing
to do with COVID itself.
- So you didn't
finish the sentence.
How worried are you about,
oh, so you're saying.
- How worried are you that
we're at the beginning
of finding out what really
the repercussions
of the vaccines?
- Oh, I'm not worried
I know it to be true.
- Jesus.
- That's, that's a fact.
You know, I tour with
folks like Ryan Cole.
As Ryan says, the
cells don't lie.
What he sees on his
glass slide isn't fake.
It's not a deep fake and
the cancers are popping up.
There's, there's a lot
of things going on here.
And now this
hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal
axis issue,
Dr. Walker, in a moment of
clarity in his own twisted way
in that last video,
basically gave us a pre-read
on, on the situation.
He said, can you
imagine, there's whites-
I'm paraphrasing.
If there's widespread
global damage
and we've damaged the
whole next generation.
And his response to that was,
I would have to take
Pfizer off my resume.
The violin is a microscopic
that I'm gonna have
to play for that.
But.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Be that as it may,
even Dr. Walker
recognizes that the
civil,
the disruption in the fabric of,
of civil society will be huge.
I've traveled over 400,000 miles
last year on commercial air
and then privates
also a lot of time
seeing a lot of people.
And unfortunately it's not
slowing down this year.
I wish it was.
And there is a deep
anger right now.
It is, it is.
I often refer to
Yeates' Second Coming
and the slouching beast
towards Bethlehem.
There is slouching
Beast is out there and,
and things could
get very, very ugly
and we absolutely do
not need violence.
It will, it will be met
with overwhelming force.
It's absolutely not
what we need right now.
But a lot of people are
really, really angry
and they're getting angrier.
And meanwhile,
Pfizer and the governments and
the World Health Organization
and the WEF are all digging in
and they kind of are
in our face, basically.
Like I say, telling
us to go pound sand,
you know, Justin
Trudeau, et cetera.
So, you know, New
Zealand, those poor souls,
they finally get out
under Jacinda Ardern
and they get somebody
who's even worse.
- Yeah, it's, it's
just incredible.
And they're a tiny island
that could've dealt with this
in a completely.
- Yeah.
- Completely different way.
So gimme something.
Look we could do this.
First off, you're welcome
to come back anytime to,
to amplify anything that
you want to talk about
in the future, of course.
But, but try to help
me end this in a way
that's gonna give people
a little positivity.
I mean, we had sort of reach
out to your neighbor, but yeah.
- I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna do the
book pump thing.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Okay.
Lies my government told me
and the better future coming.
What better future?
What the heck is
he talking about?
What I hear all over the world
is the emergence of belief
that there is a,
a path forward that can
potentially enable us
to fulfill more of our
potential as a human species.
In a world that
rather than becoming
this centralized totalitarian,
I argue fascist, or we
could call it corporatist,
if you want to use
nice, nice words.
Marxist utilitarian,
fourth industrial revolution,
transhumanism world
that the World Economic Forum
wants to shape and thrust on us.
There is another way
in its movement towards
networks of decentralized
communities.
Which in a way is what those,
those rich white guys 250
years ago came up with.
You know, they
were pretty smart.
They did a whole lot of
thinking and reading,
and they were trying
to solve a problem
that's not so different from
the one we face right now.
Only on a smaller scale.
And I think they came up
with some pretty good stuff
in the form of the
Declaration of Independence,
Constitution and Bill of Rights
and the whole idea of
a Federalist government
in which the nation state
has very limited powers
in authority and
responsibility for things like
external defense and
regulating interstate commerce.
I think what we all, what I
hear, except for the monopolist,
you know, I, I can't
speak for Bill Gates,
but for likes of you and I,
what I hear again and again is
people just kind of wanna be
left alone to live their lives
and not told what to do
and not told that they
have to, you know,
have digital ideas attached
to their carbon credits and,
you know, forced to have
a social credit score
in order to get a mortgage
or buy a car, or, you
know, whatever the hell.
We just, you know, guys,
just leave us alone.
Let us, let us
teach our own kids.
Don't force-
We would not even go there.
All this other garbage
on our children.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Yeah, that's, that's
a whole other topic.
- Just leave us alone.
- I have a feeling
I know your feelings.
- And, and,
and allow us to live in a
world in which we can trade
and engage in transactions
with each other
for goods and services
and live our lives.
And I'm told, you know,
so that's one of the
big focuses of the book.
It's things like, you know,
start a victory garden,
et cetera,
and some practical things
about what you can do
about our federal
government right now.
What's an ongoing,
and what Trump tried
to do that I think was,
there was a bunch of good
that Trump tried to do.
He's, he's unfortunately, he,
he can't control certain
aspects of his personality,
but he did a lot of good and
he had a lot of good ideas
about the government and about
the administrative state.
And I'm not sure,
I think personally
that we've had,
these guys have been planning
this since World War II.
And arguably even
earlier than that.
And we're not gonna turn this
around in the next two years.
We may not turn it around
during our generation,
but I think it's a
worthwhile fight to fight
for the sake of our children.
And, and I think we can,
there's something out
there on the horizon
of a better way for humanity
to really fulfill its potential
by being able to
work cooperatively.
But not in a way
that's from each
according to his abilities,
to each according to his needs.
And, and I think that
that's the better future.
I think we can go there.
I think we can build towards
it in an incremental way.
And the phrase that's often
used is intentional communities.
And if, if you're
a fan of Ayn Rand,
you may have or may
not have noticed
the name of my Substack,
who is Robert Malone.
- I got it.
- Which is direct reference
to John Galt.
- I'm in Galt's Gulch
over here in Florida.
I shouldn't have said that,
but yeah, there you go.
- And, and I consider
our little 50 acres here
to be our own
personal Galt's Gulch.
So I think that
what you're expressing is that
you already have your mind
wrapped around the idea of
small intentional communities
and the value that they bring.
And I think we have
to build a new system,
kind of organically,
within this larger
super structure
that's basically gonna
collapse around our ears
in the next few years
and hope that we can
weather the storm
and come out the other side
and we can be the
examples for an,
you know, a new way
forward rather than this,
you know, Terminator Matrix.
I mean, how many times do
we have to see those movies?
Okay?
Mad Max.
- Terminator, Matrix.
Minority Report, Idiocracy.
- I do not want to live
in Mad Max world.
- It's all there.
Dr. Malone, you, you
ended it beautifully.
I appreciate it.
And as I often say
to my audience,
I have nothing better to
do than save the world.
I suspect you don't either.
So, enjoy your 50
acres and as I said,
anytime you want
something amplified,
please reach out and we'll
help as much as we can.
- Thank you.
Thanks for the, the time spent
and look forward
to our next chat.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.